you look fantastic girl thank you did
you pick this out is this your creation
like what is it's beautiful well you
know me and my stylish and my publishers
really really putting stuff together now
shall we we just like uh a mechanical
team and we just come up with a
brilliant idea is this beautiful are you
gonna start your own fashion line huh
you gonna start your own fashion line
I am collaborating I am collaborating
with a fashion company nice and you know
what I'm gonna make I'm gonna make it
look very hip I'm gonna look very
expensive-looking but very under the
budget yeah cuz you know not everybody
gosh money getting like that mm-hm so
I'm collaborating you're gonna see a
showgirl
oh no way I have to tell you you are an
inspiration to so many women out there
for your story your strength the way you
have handled this whole amazing dream of
yours that's coming true have you had a
chance to kind of reflect on what's
happening in your career you know we
every single time my night time or not
now when I donate time but it's just
like you know when I'm feeling really
stressed out because in order to be here
you got to work a lot mm-hmm and you got
to think of your steps and when you
think about your next steps
you know you stressed out a lot so you
need a like I mean some time to myself
and be like hey remember where you at
right now I remember where you was at
one year ago or two years ago relax
enjoy it be happy it's gonna happen and
you're happy I'm happy
you're happy I'm happy and it's a lot of
work you know other work a lot of people
see the the good and it's like I don't
see the yeah tiredness and your work is
paying off boudic yellow it was number
one on the Billboard charts the last
time that happened as a solo was Lauryn
Hill I think was in 98 I think when you
found that out that must have been such
a moment for you it was a moment and it
was just like something that is like
wait a minute I did yeah I what I really
wanted was to get on the billboards and
my
use it to train and to be taken
seriously to be played on the radio
station so per meter gold number one is
just like wow I can't believe that
happened to me like and and it's like
I'm proud of it because I really did
that I really put in work for it and
it's like it's well deserved I feel like
everybody even people that don't like me
was listening and playing the song so
it's like hot deserts to be here nobody
could take that credit fun it's the song
of the year everyone loves the song I
just think I can just dance right now
just thinking about it so great and you
got a Grammy nomination two Grammy
nominations how did you find out about
that I found out about that the day that
you know they are now saying this is
like yes and it's like I was so happy to
be nominated that I'm like oh my gosh
what happened if I wouldn't like oh my
gosh I can't believe I'm bigger looks
like that would put that icing on the
cake yes you know what else is icing on
the cake is that ring I can't stop
looking congratulations thank you this I
think one of the happiest things that I
could go with yeah yeah cuz that guy
that was a woman's dream it was a big
surprise when he did it publicly and yes
out on stage what was that moment for
you that moment for me I was I didn't I
couldn't believe you know cuz I know you
had to give me a really big gift because
he wasn't there for my birthday he was
in it was Tori oh and you know I know he
was gonna give me something big because
he's extravagant but I thought he was
gonna give me like a watch or something
for him to go all that his way to give
me a ring to contact my mother to be
there and it's just like wow this man
really loves me here and I love him too
so what is a cardi B wedding um you know
me and him we really like we really like
a lot you know really like a lot so it
has to be extremely beautiful a lot of
flowers a lot of shiny shiny shiny and
very gangster you know what I'm saying I
want
say I do mom start shooting in the air
like that bad like that's the type of
things that I want you know what I'm
saying I want like like in the reception
I want people to have fun I don't want
it to be a boring and wedding I want
like when I put dance or music people
start doing splits on the floor I wanted
to be a gangsta fun party like I wanted
to be a day to remember forever you know
you know like you know I heard that is
really really stressful to get ready for
it so it's like I want the stress to be
worth it I want delicious food you know
I went to a wedding and the food sticks
a little so you know it just has to be
all the way to the top I don't want
nobody to complain not one bit of my
petunia can I come
yep she invited me I'm going to card
Evie's wedding yeah just can somebody
take a name down cuz I love huge she's
invited some good I love dancing I'm not
a great dancer but I'll dance girl girl
we gotta have some fun we're gonna